[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum militär das ja
alles schön dass sie dabei sind
wir zeichnen die angehörigen des
österreichischen bundesheeres aus die
besonderes geleistet haben und zwar in
folgenden kategorien rekrut des jahres
zivilbedienstete des jahres einheit des
jahres soldat des jahres und die
sonderkategorie die an die miliz geht
und wir beginnen gleich mit kategorie
eins wer wird held des jahres dafür ist
die große frage
hier kommt ein überblick für sie aller
nominierten in alphabetischer
reihenfolge
nominiert als rekrut des jahres sind
gefreiter valentin banker hat aufgrund
seines umfangreichen wissens im bereich
steuerung und programmierung von drohnen
für einen voll autonomen flug wesentlich
zur fähigkeit entwicklung beigetragen
gefreiter themas adolf wird aufgrund der
kugel krise bereits nach zwei wochen
basisausbildung ins post
verteilerzentrum hagenbrunn ab
kommentiert dort zeichnet er sich durch
seine stets vorhandene motivation
besonders aus gefreiter lorenz
schörghuber ist nicht nur ein äußerst
umsichtiger und besonders soldaten
vertreter er wächst in der zeit des
lokals zur echten stütze des
kompaniekommandanten heran
während des jahres wird das verrät uns
jetzt der kommandant der streitkräfte
generalleutnant franz reißner sehr
geehrte zuseher und zuseherinnen ist
freut mich ganz besonders heute einen
jungen kameraden zu ehren der durch
seinen einsatz sein engagement seine
leistungsbereitschaft seinen
grundwehrdienst äußerst erfolgreich
absolviert hat dieser junger kamerad ist
gefreiter valentin denke weil in den
banker hat seinen grundwehrdienst in der
wach sicherungs compagnie am
fliegerhorst promos kinnlangen leben
begonnen wurde aber aufgrund seiner
zivil erworbenen fähigkeiten schon nach
kurzer zeit dem element elektronische
kampfführung zu drohnen abwehr zugeteilt
durch das umfangreiche wissen vom
gefreiten bänke in den bereichen
steuerung und programmierung von drohnen
für einen voll autonomen flug konnten
auch für die eigene 1 satzführung zu
drohnen abwehr neue bestens verwertbare
erkenntnisse gewonnen werden
bereits vor seiner zeit als
grundwehrdiener entwickelte unser junger
kamerad eine durch das system ältere
nicht erfassbare voll flugfähige drohne
mit einer zuladung kapazität bis zu drei
kilo gefreiter bänke stellte seine
entwicklung und das damit verbundene
know how to im bundesheer jederzeit zur
verfügung die fähigkeitsentwicklung um
so das kaderpersonal konnte dadurch im
hinblick auf risikobewusstsein und
technische machbarkeit sowie zukünftige
angriffsvektoren mittels autonome
thronen wesentlich gesteigert werden
weiters entwickelte gefreiter bänke mit
seiner grundwehrdienern eine software
zur simulation des dritten funksystems
konrad so dass in zukunft das erlernen
der bedienung mittels fernausbildung
ohne funkgerät möglich ist eine
wesentliche effizienzsteigerung in der
ausbildung gefreiter bänke präsentierte
sich während seiner zeit als
grundwehrdiener stets als korrekter und
loyaler soldat der sein exzellentes
fachwissen dem österreichischen
bundesheer gerne zur verfügung stellte
ich darf herrn gefreiten bänke herzlich
zu dieser ausserordentlichen
gratulieren und ihm alles gute auf
seinem weiteren lebensweg wünschen
ein gefragter als schulkamerad der
führungsunterstützung schule darf ich
ihnen mit stolz den award weingut des
jahres 2020 überreichen
[Musik]
rekrut des jahres 2020 valentin bänke
drohnen spezialist bereits im alter von
14 jahren wird er in niederösterreich in
einen begabten förderungsprogramm für
roboter aufgenommen
kurz darauf folgt die erste teilnahme
bei einer meisterschaft da ging es darum
dass mit drohnen einfach einen fahrenden
roboter nach frieden ist ich habe das so
fasziniert dass ich dann gesagt im
nächsten jahr okay was drauf vier jahren
machen nochmal mit aber die sachen mit
die leidenschaft für drohnen ist
unaufhaltsam geweckt als drohnen experte
hat valentin denke auf jeden fall einen
beruf mit zukunft gefunden
die einsatzmöglichkeiten der unbemannten
fluggeräte wachsen stetig an
ich glaube es gibt ein paar
entwicklungsbereiche wo sehr stark
angetrunken also was man immer wieder
ließ die paketzustellung das wird sich
in den nächsten jahren noch eine größere
rolle spielen und vor allem in afrika
wird es bereits tagtäglich eingesetzt
das paket da geht es aber nicht um
normale pakete sondern auch medikamente
und so lernt schon tagtäglich mit
drohnen verschickt und wohnen auch ganz
großen uns in der landwirtschaft weil
ich dann natürlich einfach mit ganz
großen drohnen die felder abfliegen kann
und keinen traktor braucht er durch und
also das sind die zwei wirklich großen
angebot bereichern
zurzeit studiert bänke maschinenbau an
der tu wien den drohnen sind erst der
anfang die faszination luftfahrt und
auch richtung raumfahrt
ich werde mich sicher noch länger
methoden beschäftigen aber langfristig
gesehen möchte ich mich dann eher auf so
genannten fixing drohnen spezialisieren
also was man immer
wir unternahmen einfach flugzeug kennt
weil da ist einfach schon da ist heute
schon mit der reichweite deutlich größer
und das ist noch spannender zum fliegen
weil da braucht man schon ein bisschen
ein geschickter sonst fliegt eine drohne
die stehen in der luft da zurück ich
nach rechts und links nach rechts auf
einen flieger das ist schon ein bisschen
ja schon ein bisschen kunst beides zu
steuern und so denkt rekrut des jahres
2020 valentin denke über seine
auszeichnung
ich finde es ein großes zugeständnis war
es einfach bedeutet dass meine arbeit
den leuten wichtig war dass ich einen
bleibenden eindruck hinterlassen habe
und dass meine arbeit einfach wert
geschätzt worden
[Musik]
tegut des jahres wahlen sind denke einen
herzlichen glückwunsch auch von uns in
der nächsten folge zeichnen wir den
zivilbediensteten des jahres aus machen
sie's gut und bleiben sie gesund
[Musik]